happy 2017 guys welcome to one of my
first vlogs and I started this vlog out
by being in Pittsburgh at the airport
for 10 oh my god it's so early and we're
heading back to LA it's snowing the dog
won't eat his food
hi honey
I don't like it if you do
this is what I look like when I travel
with my dog he's so good he just sits in
waits do you hear me talking man I'm
talking about you
what is that Gemma man he's already
sleeping now clearly it's a few days
later and I'm back last night was New
Year's he got super super wild basically
it involved a lot of yelling and I was
yelling at Matt and I kind of feel bad
for yelling he was so convinced that he
was right and I was so convinced that I
was I was right because I actually was
right so I clearly was convinced he was
just delusional the fight was about
pizza you know me stomach he was telling
me that fresh brothers pizza was
homemade from scratch there at the
restaurant and I said no that's absurd
it is not just seen hateful hoods
hi how are you I'm Yoshi mind you guys
make your dough from scratch or is it
like pre-made it's pre-made okay just
wondering so I called the restaurant and
they confirmed that it in fact wasn't
made from scratch but the restaurant
that I ordered from I knew 100% they
actually made their dough there this is
such a stupid absurd fight but of course
I had to call that restaurant just to a
hundred percent confirmed to Matt that
they did in fact make their dough and
now these are the kind of fights that we
have my own food years
so happy new year way to start off the
year in a super positive positive way I
also I'm not sure if I posted it yet but
I added in all of my 2016 videos
together into one massive video that's a
thing it happened I'm not really sure
how I feel about it and I haven't posted
it yet at the time of me making this
current video so I have no idea what the
feedback is but that's the best thing
about YouTube there's always another day
if you have a bad day on YouTube guess
what there's tomorrow you can try again
editor's note
last night I was exporting my 9 and a
half hour video of all of my 2016 videos
and my computer came unplugged so I'm
trying again and it keeps failing so I
promise you this video will be up soon
how soon hmm I'm not sure but it's gonna
be great
and bonus points for anybody who watches
the entire nine hours
I wouldn't recommend watching it all in
one sitting because that might make you
hate me or it might make you love me
it's debatable I just got back from JB's
birthday party and speaking of failing
and trying again tomorrow
the entire vlog that I was filming at my
microphone wasn't plugged in all the way
so I'm gonna have to do a little vo edit
of this video that is has no audio so
let's start off this vo sol we and
probably was talking about how cute
Maddie was talking about oh goody it's
2017 so excited and then we go into
Matt's apartment and everyone's so
excited to see Maddie Maddie Maddie
Maddie where's Jenna there's Jenna Matt
decides to test out my lens because he
likes it and I think I'm not mad at him
anymore so everything is great look at
us best friends I don't know what I'm
saying I think I was excited that I was
out of the house um Maddie's cute
obviously then oh look I spotted Edie
Ed's here he said something funny about
the dishwasher about his hand I don't
remember but I guess it doesn't matter I
think I was getting a little frustrated
because no one was leaving the house and
Matt decides to take a shot and I said
shot shot shot just shot to get in the
freaking car so I can go to the grocery
store I've got items to get let's let's
roll look at Matty beans a cute back
there we're now at the grocery store so
I'm looking for the card aisle didn't
know that my microphone wasn't plugged
in uh we make it to the card aisle I
found a great card it had some great vo
talking about cake but you can't hear it
and now we're looking for a cake Jenna
wanted this one because it was a Steeler
themed cake that I saw this Oreo cake
and I was like oh that looks good then
we debated does JB like Oreos of course
JB likes Oreos but then we spot this
cake it is a beautiful cake made for
probably a six year old a six year old
girl
JB is anything but a six year old girl
but then I say you know what it's cool
let's get it and little did I know that
this cake was gonna be the most
delicious cake ever I spotted something
I walk over to it what is it what could
it be
it's Ninja Turtle plates water don't
would not want a Ninja Turtle plates if
you're an adult and you wouldn't want a
Ninja Turtle plates at your party I will
be at your party I am so sorry but I
can't make it I've got to RSVP no now I
gotta go pay for the cake so I'm walking
and watching this video I realized I
think I need a haircut like a slight
trip and we're here everything is
awesome and my audio is back yeah
JB Jeff first birthday you're not afraid
on the phone on the phone
remember when you didn't get tomato soup
I love everyone thank you so that leads
me to here currently sitting in my
kitchen in a weird sweater type thing
and talking to you guys so yeah that's a
great way to start 2017 off so I guess
I'll see you tomorrow like I said we're
just just try again tomorrow
love you guys bye okay this is the cake
I'm unsure anything about anything it is
the one pure birth inspired inspired by
the film this looks just like a date on
Pinterest it doesn't really look much
like the picture that I tried hate
Pinterest cuz everybody's like book of
me and I'm over you